die Innenstadt von saporisha in der
Einkaufsstraße klafft jetzt eine Lücke
gerissen von einer russischen
iskandarakete im Erdgeschoss war ein
Supermarkt nebenan eine Weinhandlung ein
ganz normales wohnen finden am 6 oktober
um 4 Uhr
schlug das Geschoss ein Datum die
Uhrzeit wird Olga nie mehr vergessen
doch bei dir eine Frau wurde nur
gerettet weil sie eine Pfeife hatte sie
fanden sie dann unter den Trümmern
Olgas Wohnung grenzt direkt an das Haus
das jetzt nicht mehr da ist die
Krankenschwester führt uns in ihr zu
Hause Olga willensaporischer bleiben
trotz allem was sie und ihr Ehemann
erlebt haben
diese Mauer hätte auf uns stürzen können
mein Ehemann stand hier und ich lag dort
und über uns die Klimaanlage sie hätte
auch unterstützen können alles hätte
passieren können
von diesem Inferno waren Olga und ihr
Mann nur durch eine Mauer getrennt und
diese drohte zu bersten durch die
Explosion durch das Feuer es war ein
stundenlanger Kampf der Feuerwehr
15 Menschen starben aber sechs Menschen
wurden aus den Trümmern gerettet
[Musik]
Valentin sezenko hatte den Einsatz
geleitet seit 13 Jahren arbeitet er als
Feuerwehrmann in saporisha seit neun
Monaten unter Luftangriffen
die Dynamik unserer Einsätze hat sich
dramatisch verändert in den letzten
Monaten
die russische Armee hat saporizia immer
schwerer bombardiert
valentin ist kein Mann vieler Worte er
von Taten der evakuierte die letzten
Zivilisten aus dem Stahlwerk in Mario
Poll half hunderten Ukrainern beim
Überqueren der Frontlinie seine Frau
erfuhr davon erst nach den Einsätzen
sie weiß nicht was ich mache
meine Frau erzähle ich nichts über meine
Arbeit ich denke das ist der bessere Weg
ich muss sie doch nicht noch beunruhigen
und Sorgen haben die Menschen in
saporischer genug wir filmen einen
Probelauf samt Vorführeffekt
Valentin erträgt es gelassen zumindest
äußerlich er weiß was sein Team bei
jedem der bisherigen Luftangriffe
geleistet hat
saporisha am kniepro gelegen bekannt
durch das nahe AKW und für seine
Schwerindustrie Rüstungskonzerne
inbegriffen die Stadt braucht Strom und
den will Russland ihr durch Luftangriffe
nehmen über 200.000 Menschen sind
geflüchtet wer geblieben ist lebt den
Alltag einer Front statt geprägt von
Stromabschaltung Luftangriffen und
sorgen vor dem näher rückenden Winter
gute Geschäfte machen im Moment Outdoor
Läden vom Bunsenbrenner bis zur
Taschenlampe gefragt ist alles was von
der städtischen Grundversorgung
unabhängig macht oder nicht früher haben
wir die Menschen für die Berge für die
Wildnis ausgerüstet jetzt helfen wir
dass Sie zu Hause überleben
einer der dort systematisch einkauft ist
olexi Hausverwalter von 200 Wohnungen
hier habe ich langhaltbare
Nahrungsmittel dort Kartuschen und
Campingausrüstung
es ist nicht nur für den Eigenbedarf der
Familienvater hat die Keller in Bunker
umgebaut zu Beginn des Krieges hatten
bis zu 50 Personen hier unten aus unter
ihnen auch olexie seine Frau und die
kleine Tochter unzählige Male
wir waren in der Stadt in einem
Einkaufszentrum dann sah meine Tochter
einen süßigkeitenstand sie sagte zu uns
oh ich will Bonbons kaufen und sie
später im Bunker essen Kinder dürfen
doch nicht so aufwachsen das war der
Moment in dem meine Frau und ich
entschieden haben dass sie flüchten
müssen
seine Lebensmittel reichen für Wochen
gleichzeitig dienen sie als Schutz vor
Glassplittern er ist froh dass seine
Tochter nicht mehr in so einer Wohnung
leben muss wo Gasmasken und
Notstromaggregate zur Ausstattung
gehören
zu Hause fühlt man sich doch sonst immer
sicher jetzt überlegst du wie schützt
man sich gegen Glassplitter die Wände
deiner Wohnung können zur töd die Falle
werden wenn sie zusammenbrechen
seine Familie wohnt jetzt in Deutschland
seitdem sei er ruhiger geworden sagt
olixi der einzig wahre Schutz für sie
war die Flucht ins Ausland das
Meerschweinchen und er eine WG auf
unbestimmte Zeit
[Musik]
Familientreffen am Telefon
Mutter und Tochter erzählen von ihrem
Tagesausflug nach Holland
wie schön sie waren in Amsterdam
und doch übermannt ihn Traurigkeit mit
der Nacht kommt die Ausgangssperre die
Straßenbeleuchtung ist ausgeschaltet um
das Stromnetz zu entlasten wir begleiten
eine Polizeistreife Filmen mit
Infrarotkamera auch nachts droht die
größte Gefahr aus dem Himmel Viktor und
seine Kollegen fürchten vor allem die
tiefliegenden Drohnen die Russland
neuerdings einsetzt
in der Dunkelheit ist es wichtig alle
Sinne zu nutzen nicht nur die Augen wir
müssen auch hören was um uns herum
geschieht
ihre Streifen dienen auch dazu Plünderei
vor zur beugen aber tausende sind aus
saporischer geflüchtet seit Kriegsbeginn
ihre Häuser und Wohnungen stehen nun
leer
kurz vor 1 Uhr fällt ein Passant auf er
hat keine Sondergenehmigung die ihm
erlaubt die Ausgangssperre zu brechen
er wurde verhört und durchsucht es
wurden keine Waffen und auch keine
verbotenen Substanzen bei ihm gefunden
wir haben mit ihm ein aufklärendes
Gespräch geführt
und ihn dann nach Hause gefahren
saftige Geldstrafen drohen nur
Wiederholungstätern
saporischer bei Nacht die Stadt ruht bis
der nächste Luftangriff erfolgt